December is here and Santa's come early
giving us a few awesome games you're
going to want to check out it's a new
week and that means time for new
releases first up Just Cause 3 it set
several years after the events just
cause 2 Rico Rodriguez leaves the agency
and returns to his homeland but there's
an evil dictator problem so he's gotta
blow stuff up now let's talk about the
sandbox the map size is on par with Just
Cause two with 400 square miles but the
volumetric terrain has increased to
allow more verticality what does that
mean it means now it's possible for the
player to explore subterranean caverns
and scale buildings more effectively and
realistically the world of the game is
composed of five major biomes each
having unique landmarks and landscapes
you'll get your signature grappling hook
and parachute as use but they've added a
wing suit so you essentially get to fly
over the world like a modern day jesus
play in the world silly a sandbox on the
first but if that doesn't float your
boat you can try tom clancy's rainbow 6
siege that puts heavy emphasis on
environmental destruction and co-op
different operators have different
nationalities perks abilities and
equipment like a dude named twitch who's
equipped with drone that can stun
enemies electric shock while smoke has
the ability to detonate poison players
can breach charge ceilings and floors as
well as ambushing enemies by repelling
through breakable windows and there's
even procedural destruction system so
you can essentially shoot or blow up
anything to free those hostages co-op is
key on the first but hey if you got a
wii u we got something for you Xenoblade
Chronicles X is a massive open world
game the developer claimed it's bigger
than any open world game available yeah
I'm including fallout 4 traveling can
take place on foot or in a large
humanoid robot approximately four times
the height of a normal playable
character they're called scales and
scales of the ability to fly traverse
water and transform into vehicles such
as motorcycles and
Thanks aerial battles will take place in
the game and they look sweet as hell but
it takes a long time to get there you
don't get your scelan till about halfway
through the game so if you want that
mech well buckle up buttercup you're in
for the long haul pick your mac on the
fourth a few other games you might
remember chivalry medieval warfare that
was that pc game that was pretty hot a
couple years ago and made waves with
that low gravity server that made
everyone yell
oh that's good stuff well it's coming to
current gen now for any newcomers to
this game it's a first person or third
person perspective using medieval
implements you know like swords maces
long bows and other weaponry of that
time then use that hack smash and rain
arrows down on anyone that gets in your
way it's stab or be stabbed on the first
and finally one of the most iconic RPG
series from Japan is coming to PC as a
full-scale action RPG and Dragon Quest
heroes the worldtrees whoa and the
blight below this week you get the
digital slime edition for pc it includes
11 additional goopy slime weapons and
two bonus maps this beauty of a game is
out on the third of December but if you
buy it before that date you get ten
percent off what's happening right now
so that's all the games coming out this
week in between Just Cause 3 or rainbow
6 siege or Xenoblade Chronicles let me
know what you are interested in picking
up I'll see you again same time next
week
you